anfang des jahres sah es kurz so aus als
würde bernd hocke aus der aus der afc
rausfliegen
damals durften wir als heute schon
natürlich nicht wegschauen deshalb
unsere aktion
aktion sorgen bernd
aktion sorgen während jetzt die gute
nachricht der afg parteitag in hannover
hat endgültig bewiesen unser bern sitzt
fester im sattel als je zuvor
ja nicht nur dass sie ihnen nicht
rausschmeißen er ist in der afc
tatsächlich so etwas wie die ja die die
braune eminenz der der strippenzieher
des faktors rechter flügel hat
inzwischen eindeutig das sagen vor allem
bei der besetzung von wichtigen
parteiämtern und das trotz seiner
berühmten denkmal der schande rede
trotz der bilder von 2010 die ihnen auf
einer lupenreinen nazi demo in dresden
zeigen ja mit reichskriegsflagge npd
leuten und allem zipp und zapp das kann
man beim besten willen nicht mehr
schönreden aber man kann es natürlich
versuchen also es war ein suchprozess
jeder mensch macht mal läuft mal in
sackgassen reihen oder probierten das
aus und ich hoffe der suche nach einer
würdigen gedenken
er hat auf der suche mit 38 quasi mitten
in der pubertät
ja da probiert man noch verrückte sachen
aus natürlich vorher war ein halbes jahr
backpacking gore danach hat dann zumba
kurs in eisenach gemacht und dann ist
halt in diese nazi demo reingeschlittert
und hat aus versehen mitgesungen
da ist es doch allen schon passiert oder
ja heute dominiert sein sogenannter
flügel ganz klar die afd
das ist tatsache um den gemäßigten ich
rette leben
der flügel kreist der flügel um den
gemäßigten georg pastowski als
parteisprecher zu verhindern hat er auf
dem parteitag eine bis dahin völlig
unbekannte frau ins rennen geschickt mit
erfolg doris von sayn-wittgenstein ja
betreiberin eines
betreiberin eines massagesalons in
heidelberg also quasi uralter massage
adel und eine top rednerin ich komme aus
einer familie die ganze auf der ganzen
welt verteilt ist ich habe auf der
ganzen welt verwandte und ich lege mir
näher als rassismus sigmund freud bis
heute der beste redenschreiber der welt
weil da muss ja ja ja haben irgendwann
sauerland geworden aber mit mir hat herr
hörte fast herzlich verhindert klar ist
dieser parteitags von hannover zeigt
einmal mehr deutlich alles was die afg
zusammenhält und islam und merkel hat
sie träumen weiter von einem autoritären
deutschland in dem sich minderheiten
endlich ganz hinten anstellen und in dem
frauen wieder ihren platz kennen
und jetzt der zweite grund warum ich
hier bin und eigentlich habe ich letzter
satz meine ok habe ich in meinen
parteikollegen peter bislang zu
verdanken der mich im wahlkampf darauf
aufmerksam machte dass frauen wie ich
eigentlich besser an einer stange tanzen
sollten dann sehr guter hinweis frau
kollegin und jetzt auch sexismus hat in
dieser partei ebenso wenig platz wie
rechtsextremismus ganz normale
bürgerliche partei die in sachen
postengeschacher und intrigen längst zu
den etablierten aufgeschlossen hat